عزله النظام الايراني لم تعد خارجيه فحسب
الباثه تكبر حتى داخليا مع توالي
الانتقادات لموجهه للمسؤولين الايرانيين
حتى من رموه السابقين النظام نفسه فبعد
بدري حسين خمنائي شقيقه المرشد الايراني
جاءت صفعه جديده للنظام هذه المره من
الرئيس الايراني الاسبق محمد خازاني الذي
اعرض عن تايده للاحتجاجات المتوسطه في
البلاد واصفا شعارها الابرز امراه حياه
حريه وقال خاتمي في بيان نظره عرشيه يوم
الطلاب انها شعار الاحتجاجات يحمل رساله
رائعه تعكس التحرك باتجاه المستقبل
خاتمي لم يتردد في توجيه سهام الانتقاد
نحو النظام الايراني حيث قال انه لا يجب
وضع الحريه والامن في مواجهه بعضهما البعض
كما دعا المسؤولين الى مد يد العون لطلاب
والاعتراف باخطائهم قبل فوات الاوانع
هذا وهبت روحاني من بين ابرز المسؤولين
السابقين المؤيدين للاحتجاجات في ايران
وكان خاتمي قد شاغل منصب الرئيس من العام
1997 حتى 2005 وممنع خاتمنا ظهور على
وسائل الاعلام بعد احتجاجات واسعه
اثارتها اعاده انتخاب الرئيس السابق محمود
احمد عام 2009